let's see if we can come up with some
general rules of thumb or some general
trends for oxidation states by looking
at the periodic table so first let's
just focus on the alkali metals and I'll
box them off we'll think about hydrogen
in a second well I'm going to box I'm
going to separate hydrogen because it's
kind of a special case but if we look at
the alkali metals the Group one elements
right over here we've already talked
about the fact that they're not too
electronegative they have that one
valence electron they wouldn't mind
giving away that electron and so for
them that oxidation state might not even
be a hypothetical charge these are very
good candidates for actually forming
ionic bonds and so it's very typical
that when these are in a molecule when
these form bonds that these are the
things that are being oxidized they give
away an electron so they get to an
occipital oxidation state for them would
be positive one if we will one group
over if we go one group over right over
here to the alkaline earth metals two
valence electrons still not too
electronegative so they're likely to
fully give or partially give away two
electrons so if you're forced to assign
a high on ik if you were say well none
of this partial business just give it
all away or take it all or take it you
would say well these would typically
have an oxidation state of positive two
they would hypothet in a hypothetical
ionic bonding situation they would be
more likely to give the two electrons
because they not too electronegative and
they'd only have it would take them a
lot to complete their valence shell to
get all the way to eight now let's go to
the other side of the periodic table to
group let's go to group seven the
halogens the halogens right over here
they're quite electronegative sitting on
the right-hand side of the periodic
table they are one electron away from
from being satisfied from a valence
electron point of view so these are
typically reduced they typically have an
oxidation state of negative one and I
keep saying typically because these are
not going to always be the case there
are other things that could happen but
this is a typical rule of thumb that
they will there lie
we don't want to gain an electron if we
move over one group to the left group 6
and that's where the famous oxygen sits
we already said that when something is
that oxidizing something is doing to
something what oxygen would have done
that oxidation is taking electrons away
from it so these these groups are
typically oxidized and oxygen is a is a
very good oxidizing agent or another way
of thinking about as oxidant is oxygen
normally takes away electrons these like
to take away electrons typically two
electrons and so their oxidation state
is typically negative 2 once again just
a just a rule of thumb or that they are
their charge is reduced by two electrons
so these are typically reduced these are
typically oxidized now we could keep
going if we were to grow to the if we
were to go right over here to the group
five elements typical occipital
oxidation state is negative 3 and so you
see a general trend here and that
general trend and once again it's not
even a hard and fast rule of thumb even
for the extremes but as you get closer
and closer to the middle of the periodic
table you have more variation in what
these typical oxidation states could be
now I mentioned that I put hydrogen
aside because if you really think about
it hydrogen yes it has one hydrogen only
has one electron and so you could say
well maybe it wants to give away that
electron to get to 0 electrons that
could be a reasonable configuration for
hydrogen but you could also view
hydrogen kind of like a halogen so you
could kind of view it kind of like an
alkaline metal but you could in theory
it could have been put here on the
periodic table as well you could have
put hydrogen here because hydrogen in
order to complete its first shell it
just needs one electron so in theory
hydrogen could have been put there so
hydrogen actually could it typically
could have a positive or a negative 1
oxidation oxidation state and just to
see an example of that let's think about
a situation where hydrogen is the
oxidizing agent and an example of that
would be
TM hydride lithium lithium hydride right
over here now in lithium hydride you
have the situation where hydrogen is
more electronegative a lithium is not
too electronegative it would happily
give away an electron and so in this
situation hydrogen is the one that's
that's oxidizing the lithium lithium is
reducing the hydrogen hydrogen is the
one that is hogging the electron so the
oxidation state on the lithium here is a
positive one and the oxidation state on
the hydrogen here is a negative so just
a once again I really want to make sure
we get the notation lithium has been
oxidized by the hydrogen hydrogen has
been reduced by the lithium now let's do
let's give an example where hydrogen
plays the other role let's imagine
hydroxide so the hydroxide anion so you
have a hydrogen and an oxygen it's the
Sencha you could think of a water
molecule that loses a hydrogen proton
but keeps that hydrogen's electron and
this has a negative charge this has a
negative one charge but what's going on
right over here and actually let me just
draw that because it's fun to think
about it so this is a situation where
oxygen typically has one two three four
five six electrons and then when it's
water you have you have two hydrogen's
you have two hydrogen's like that and
then you share and then you have
covalent bond right over there sharing
that pair covalent bond sharing that
right over there to get to hydroxide the
oxygen essentially NAB's both of these
electrons NAB's both of these electrons
to become so you get that pair that pair
now you have let me do this in a new
color now you have this pair as well and
then you have that other covalent bond
to the other hydrogen and now this
hydrogen is now just a hydrogen proton
this one now has a negative charge so
this is hydroxide and so the whole thing
has a negative charge and oxygen is we
already talked about is more
electronegative than the hydrogen so
it's hogging hogging the electrons so
when you look at it right over here
you'd say well look hydrogen if we had
to if we're forced to remember remember
oxidation states is just an intellectual
tool which we'll find useful but if you
had to assign if you had to pretend like
this wasn't done ionic but if you had to
pretend this wasn't the covalent bond
but an ionic bond you'd say okay then
maybe this hydrogen would fully lose an
electron so it would get an oxidation
state of plus 1 it would be oxidized by
the oxygen and that the oxygen has it
actually has fully gained one electron
and you could say well if we're forced
to we could say well if we're forced
think about this as an ionic bond we'll
say it fully gains two electrons so
we'll have an oxidation state of
oxidation state of negative two and once
again the notation when you do the
superscript notation for oxidation
states and ionic charge you write the
sign after the number and this is just
the convention and now with these two
examples the whole point of it is to
show that hydrogen could have a negative
1 or positive 1 oxidation state but
there's also something interesting going
on here notice the oxidation states of
the molecules here they add up to the
whole or the oxidation states of each of
the atoms in a molecule they add up to
the entire the entire charge of the
molecule so if you add a positive 1 plus
a negative 1 you get 0 and that makes
sense because the entire molecule
lithium hydride is neutral it has no no
charge
similarly hydrogen plus 1 oxidation
state oxygen negative 2 oxidation number
or oxidation state you add those two
together you have a negative 1 total
charge for the hydroxide anion which is
exactly the charge that we have right
over there